how everyone should i'll tell you about
anti concentration of polynomials and
this is joint work with Ohan un and run
rule and the main question we're going
to talk about today is what is the
probability that polynomial takes a
fixed value let's say zero over the
hypercube so this is a basic setup I
have some polynomial or the real numbers
and I'm interested in probability that p
of x equals 0 where x is uniformly
random over the hypercube is it 0 1 we
can choose it with 1 minus 1 or 0 1 1
minus one is more convenient for us ok
so you can think of this as kind of a
real version of schwartzy problemo so if
this were over finite fields you know
the exact answer from Schwartz Appel
dimelo Lipton lemma but here we're going
to look at real valued polynomials over
a small discrete domain so why should
why is this different so to see why it's
different let's go several years to what
is known as little good offered problem
so a little bit and offered in the 1930s
as the following question so I have a
collection of numbers which are non zero
and this I did the exact same question
for the real function what is the
maximum possible probability that the
waiter some of the excise takes a fixed
value let's say zero and they showed
that this bound was think something like
it moves login over root n ok and this
was later improved by air dish 2 1 over
root n
so as n goes to infinity this is little
one unlike what happens for the finite
fields and today I want to ask a similar
question for higher degree polynomials
what happens with degree 2 and degree 3
and so on so before talking about higher
degree polynomials let's think about
what the right parameterize inch
parameterization should be so here n was
the number of nonzero coefficients ok is
that a good measure when we talk about
degree two polynomials well there's one
pathological example already which is x
1 x let's say so is a polynomial that
the number of nonzero coefficients is
big by the probability that it is 0 or
let's say 0 is half so I the measure
that we are looking for should be able
to distinguish these polynomials from
other polynomials ok so this is an
important definition called the rank
number of nonzero disjoint monomials of
degree D in a degree D polynomial so
have a degree polynomial then the rank
of p is the number of disjoint monomials
of degree D in the support of the
coefficients of the polynomial for
example if P is say then rank of P is n
okay then you can generalize it to more
things so with this definition let me
state the theorem which I'll state the
theorem then I'll describe some
applications and motivations okay the
theorem is that for every p of degree d
and lack of p equals R
going to be a min of two terms first is
and just write this as altogether
sit in the one over 91 / 4d yeah this is
our to the one or 4d there are some poly
log terms lurking there so let's ignore
that but it's basically saying that as
rank goes to infinity the probability
that it takes the value of zero is going
to 0 okay at the rate of our to the one
would be okay and second bond is going
to be very good in the rank but it has a
worse dependence on the degree
so so let's let's not worry about the
exact specifications here but let's
concentrate on what the right order is
so this is saying that the probability
is roughly 10 root are up to some poly
log log terms okay the saying is our to
the one or 4d up to some foil all terms
okay so in particular if d is off one
then this is less than or equal to or
double till the one by root are okay up
to some lower order terms it's exactly
one over root are just like in the
linear case so for constant degree
polynomials you're getting almost what
you had for linear things and if d is
let's say log in over 100 then you get
this is like maybe point zero zero one
so this is a statement of the results
that you have these non-trivial bounce
on the probability that a degree
polynomial takes a fixed value ok any
questions about statement yeah ok so i
guess this hundred should be let's say
log in to the square root then this is 2
to the minus omega square root Logan
right
I have five more minutes so let me tell
you why we were looking at it and what
are the applications of this so that's a
very good question so how far I offer
these bounds so right answer cannot be
better than a to the d by root R ok so
you need to get an exponential loss on
the degree and the root R is kind of
tight just as from the linear case okay
so before going on let me say a few
words about previous work this was
studied by Costello towel Andrew and
then bye Roz parag and viola before us
and they got roughly
like our to the minus 1 over 2 to the D
think so
it was non-trivial only when D was
roughly log log n but we can do up to
root login or almost log n so that's the
statement of the result it's a you can
think of it as selfish watchable dimelo
Lipton lemma for real numbers gives much
better bounce then watch a good x factor
finite fields and the applications let
me just say couple of words
so so I we were motivated to study this
question from perspective of
approximating the parity function by low
degree polynomials so this was a
question posed by Roseboro and viola
they called it a challenge so does there
exist a degree log n polynomial such
that the probability the polynomial
computes the parity exactly is more than
a half
okay there's this question does there
exist a degree log and bass two
polynomial say such that it has better
any better than random guessing
advantage over computing parity and they
used that result to get this is
raspberry and viola I know fer degree
less than log log n using our approach
we can improve it to
again I'm hiding all constant factors
here degree login or log log n so it's
still off from the challenge of log in
base 2 but we are closer than before do
we know if we allow ourselves like
hundred times log M is it known to do it
or what's no meal that can do it if
you're our come one like what what's the
lowest degree polynomial to do then and
larger than half you mean like zero
point 50-100 truly anything love only
anything any non zero correlation see
and it can actually there's a deeper
motivation I think but I can't go into
it here and so this is one application
there's another application in the same
vein okay let me just mention that as
well
so this is
does there exist a polynomial of degree
D okay I'm sorry so take any
distribution over the hypercube okay so
now i want to approximate the or
function with respect to this
distribution by a polynomial okay so i'm
fixing the distribution d over n over 0
into the n does there exist a polynomial
of degree D such that so now i'm looking
for constant correlation or constant
error little or point 99 correlation ok
so these kinds of things appear a lot in
studying ac0 computations if you had
such an upper bound you can bootstrap it
to get such polynomials for all of s is
0 and using our work we can show that
the answer is no for degree d less than
log log in and in a much more recent
work senior sorry harsha Srinivasan m
tall used our result this this anti
concentration result for polynomials to
improve it to square root login
so these bounds are useful for studying
polynomial approximations for boolean
functions because if my polynomial is
computing a boolean function like parity
or are it places a very strong
constraint on its coefficients in
particular if the polynomial is
satisfying either of these two
properties that means it should be
taking a boolean value with probability
it with non-trivial probability in which
case we can use a result to say that
it's rank is small and then you can
build from there so with that let me
stop yeah like the other quantifiers you
mean here like there is a voltage
distribution when you say the answer is
no is that they exist it is to be right
there exists a distribution yes yes you
can also think of it in the dual world
where it says asking whether or not
there is a distribution of polynomials
which computes the or function with
error at most point zero one that's the
reason
yeah what kind of techniques oh so the
main technique here is the invariance
principle so in a sense we you have to
keep in mind that these results are
false or finite field so we have to use
something about the real numbers and the
one thing that we know about real
numbers is that there's a Gaussian
distribution so we translate the problem
to the Gaussian distribution to the
Gaussian domain and there we have very
strong bounds